true's birthday party true thompson
is growing up khloe kardashian and
tristan thompson's daughter is
officially
three years old and she had the best
birthday party ever
and look at these
chloe took to her instagram stories to
document the big to-do
full of beautiful pastel colored
balloons and appearances
by true's favorite disney princesses
of course the princesses
oh my god outside was a beautiful setup
for the kids and even a huge purple
bounce house
and each of the kiddos even had their
own cookie crafting stations
auntie kylie jenner and her daughter
stormi were in attendance at the
cousins-only all-out bash
so was kourtney kardashian who posted
this video to her instagram story
and check this out kim kardashian's son
saint
and rob kardashian's daughter dream were
there too
clearly having a blast ditto grandma
kris jenner who was spotted smiling
ear to ear it's so fun with all the kids
running around
and while the kardashian fam celebrated
together many also took to social media
to post tributes for the birthday girl
proud dad tristan took to his stories to
share an adorable throwback
with his daughter writing my princess
happy third birthday grandma chris
wished her granddaughter a happy third
birthday
and gushed you have the sweetest soul
just like your mommy
and you make us all smile every day
auntie kim called true a light
and praised her for being the most
polite for always giving everyone
lots of hugs and kisses i love that she
is the best as for mama chloe she's
spoken to
e.t many times over the years in 2019
she opened up about the possibility of
expanding her family
to give true a sibling like right now
i'm super content with just true
yeah and again i guess just i have to
see on the situation i don't feel like
it's
kind of one and done too yeah and i
never thought i would have only
one child but i am so obsessed with her
and i love it so much i definitely
don't think i would feel incomplete if i
didn't have more
but another one would just add more love
to the house so i don't know yet
fast forward to 2021 and it's still a
conversation between chloe and tristan
which fans saw on the season 20 premiere
of keeping up with the kardashians
and i just feel like it's now time
to have another kid yup
i like to hear i have been thinking
about wanting another kid for quite some
time now and i
already have a head start on that i
started the process a couple months ago
when i froze my eggs
i'm going to need you we have to like
line it up with your schedule
so i can make embryos with my frozen
eggs oh i'm all for it